ciao ragazzi ben tornato in una puntata
di vita buttata il tema della puntata di
oggi è parenti orribili per una puntata
così importante avrei potuto invitare
qui in quelli che non sono gli studios
di casa mia ma sono gli studios di casa
di altre persone uno dei miei parenti
con i quali magari abbiamo un trascorso
di vicende e vicissitudini orribili e
invece ho pensato di invitati
direttamente tutti quanti ecco perché vi
presento la mia famiglia
fondamentalmente questo è parte della
mia famiglia ci presentiamo subito siamo
da vini a guglielmo aprire gianluigi già
marcato quindi poche parole siamo
allineati gli arbitri che qui di poche
parole siamo lì niente gianluigi enrico
dice saverio e ora al contrario
davide
parliamo quindi di parenti orribili
ridendo di iniziare subito ad ascoltare
i messaggi che ne dite
rocen è arrivato uno per adesso che non
ho scorto dell'archivio rischiamo
rischia lo speed la mia storia
riguardo a natale è un po imbarazzante
che il mio cucina avevamo un po come
dire addomesticato il nostro cugino più
piccolo tipo bertuccio così possiamo
fare le cose più assurde e quindi
l'abbiamo spinto a defecare sotto il
tavolo da pranzo di tutto ricevono della
famiglia di natale questa è la storia
vuoi perdere le tele gotto mandaci il
curriculum che vogliamo fare la stessa
cosa con loro voi ci provate a farmi
fare le cose peggiori una volta mi
dicessi di andare io tu cosa fai barba
la nostra zia uccide tutti
scommetto che non ti andrebbe di andare
lì e sparare un colpo disoccupati fa eco
un giorno litigano come sempre la
piccolina fa se non la smetti mi tiro il
tag ma si fa sì che di vuoi vedere la
grande sindaco dai è così navigando
sorella finisce per sfilarsi davvero il
tempo simoneschi lì così possono serata
in ospedale a ricucire evitare i piedi
c'è un 5 ma perché quando gabriele mi
lancio una martellata in testa le ha
lanciate una martellata era un
esperimento scientifico
ragazzi ma pure beatrice il periodo di
hannibal che morse il cranio né l'avete
fatta passare come se fosse un atto di
gelosia ma non dovete mai atto di
affetto
chi è secondo voi la persona che più ha
creato diciamo casini o è stato motivo
di casini all'interno della nostra
famiglia e brevettata 21 guida per ogni
anno ha creato più panico nella famiglia
sei gay
[Risate]
[Applauso]
purtroppo per francesco che è il
fratello di lavinia non è quindi lo
terremo così così in modo da avere due
lavigne natalizio che vengo la sicilia
moda valore è un'annata forme ha detto
che voleva la salsiccia po incolta e
viene il fratello gestione del gruppo
lettino piccolini che avevo 12 anni il
fratello 18 17
abbiamo pensato troppo nel caso può
essere il piatto ma cosa è successo
però posso dire che a me è successa la
stessa cosa
mia mamma mia mamma mi disse ora avrà un
secondo fratellino tutti abbiamo il tuo
tantino telecamera mio padre che dopo il
pranzo nella classica foto posa
autoscatto natalizia decide da bonn
scoreggia tore seriale ripiantare secca
sul più bello una delle sue epiche
scoregge atomiche
proprio mentre scattava la fotografia in
quel momento tutti scattiamo per il
settore terribile chiaramente la cosa
più divertente fu che mia nonna che non
vedente poverina non riuscì ovviamente a
scappare e se sorbini tutto il profumo
natalizio sprigionato
da quel giorno ne ho fatto questo è il
padre sku regione fa vide il momento
oramai e poi il padre che esatto in
divisa o speed e premetto che la persona
orribile
sono stato io in questo caso perché ha
dovuto forse nove anni giocavo con mio
cugino di trani più piccolo di me aveva
appena iniziato a far karate quindi o
fomenta tissimo e gli dico che voglio
mostrarvi cosa cosa ha imparato e gli do
un calcio un piano tetto erano in piedi
sull'atto giocare quindi lui cade dal
letto impuntandosi praticamente con la
testa sulle stime nel cassetto maggio
kart e nulla questa è la storia di come
ho staccato e adesso di mio cugino
ho subito la stessa cosa da piccola però
da mio cugino dalla tomatelli faceva
kung fu nun karate è affatto se sì lo so
però non è andato in faccia il perché lo
voleva lui possa avere tutto spiegato
ieri ha dato il calcio un pezzo contro
la vetrina che si sa cosa fa
ne sono felice ho dentro una vetrina che
tra lei mi ha fatto da ghigliottina
rialzare il doppio prima ciao buccia
ospite vi volevo racconti si scusa
volevo raccontare di quando ero piccola
e facevo dei dispetti a mia zia
praticamente cosa facevo il mio treno la
facevamo salire su una sveglia abitavamo
e la facevamo girare su se stessa
fin quando ebbe dopo si cadeva sul
divano perché noi non sappiamo in che
modo disturbarla praticamente ea volte
dico prendevamo le sue bomboniere anche
se lei ci teneva tanto a quei mostri che
c'aveva sui mobili noi prima li
mettevamo nel congelatore poi dopo le
passavamo nel microonde
così lei si arrabbia quando ci
divertivamo ciao gabriele alzate la mano
francesco praticamente 20 membri
maschili della camera non c'è io pure io
non lo so io però ma gli amanti della
della banda truffa che aveva la cara
donna nera motivo legato a una sedia con
lo scotch ma per vedere un bel pò di
tempo
giorgio nero quanti anni avevi il 10 12
c ma fatto veramente la nostra bisnonna
che porta a 104 anni per colpire questi
scherzi
ovviamente già un po di memoria a breve
termine di alzheimer no e scordava le
cose da un momento all'altro potevo
entrare in una stanza ripeteva che tu ti
sei poi usciti rientravi tu chi sei
allora non importa si rientrava io sono
il prete sono venuti ma basta avanti
fare così e ciao speed e allora per
quanto riguarda iene di noi hanno
sbagliato come si fa allora ciao grecia
ospite per quanto riguarda gli aneddoti
di natale nella nostra famiglia non ci
siamo mai fatti reali e mi ricordo va a
14 anni che se ne madre perché non mi
non mi faceva il regalo di natale
lei tutta stizzita mia portata mi ha
risposto ti ha donato una vita fatta da
bastare allora noi nemmeno ci siamo mai
fatti i regali di natale ma da un paio
d'anni ormai facciamo in segreto e tra
parentesi quadra di noi parte due
persone ognuno ha la persona alla quale
di fare il proprio regalo
e a questa decisione
paolo però quest'anno facciamo una cosa
in più quindi se volete vederlo nella
puntata che sarà l'ultima quella del 25
noi ci tra vestiremo anche dalla persona
alla quale stiamo facendo
il regalo mio padre aveva circa tre anni
esso cugina ne aveva circa 6 e fatto
mangiare per un sacco di strada la cacca
delle pecore di server di carne
liquirizia che aveva perso un bambino
prima di lui
direi che questa è un po pesantuccia
ciao vomitare bene ma anima di gioco e
javascript e allora io un natale mentre
stavo salendo e portando a casa di mia
nonna a casa di mia zia una maglietta
con degli involtini di peperoni sono
inciampata sullo zerbino mi è scivolato
tutto sullo zerbino cioè si sono proprio
rivoltati e abbiamo deciso di rimettere
tutto quanto in italy e di ripresentare
a tavola gioco ciao cara pure noi
facciamo lo stesso come lui poteva dire
come fa vergogna
l'altra sera che ci vediamo insieme
lazio juve che vi ho portato le spire
agire da mangiare ho fatto premio tutte
spinacino a terra nel pavimento dove
cammina would cose non riprese
tovagliolo ecco poi ragazzi che facevo
le parola a messa ma non ci si può
mangiare anche un no la famiglia ogni
volta che mi lascio con un ragazzo mia
sorella diventa improvvisamente amica
prima volta me la trovo seduto in
braccio a presto così seconda volta
capitata a un mese fa ho trovata che si
sta sentendo col mio ex di due anni
quindi penso se la più infame vince il
premio cioè l'ex di due anni fa facciamo
una melodia natalizia ragazzi facciamo
guillermo già ospite ti racconto di
qualcosa che ho fatto io e non che mi
hanno fatto i miei parenti quando
eravamo piccoli mio cugino mi chiedeva
spesso di comprargli le bustine delle
carte pokémon perché eravamo entrambi
appassionati
ecco mio cugino non sa che ogni volta
che chi l'ha colta volevo prima
manomesse volta che mio fratello andammo
a casa sua e mi stavo cantando di una
delle carte che mi erano uscite lui non
sa che in realtà era sua
bruciato e ne accesso di scambiarla per
il suo game boy accertato forse ti seguo
questo canale
non lo so ma mi dispiace ho fatto il
gambo amico non sento lavatore schiera
il tuo proprio dire che non ci ha ancora
detto ma è quello che ti faceva trovare
impiccato sepolto a marchi la norma più
la palla proprio le sedute una volta
scatola e sepolto in giardino con una
mappa con una ex è venuto a trovarlo
perché abbiamo sepolto il primattore il
nome spaccati il muso sulla parete
sbattendosi porta bene i nostri quali
erano i vostri animali guida concede un
milione 800 però che è stato rubato
trocino comunque ragazzi siamo
arrabbiati di questo video io ringrazio
la mia famiglia per aver preso parte
grazie mille ragazzi
ringrazio delle nuove fermano in ordine
alta territorio ok ringrazio ancora una
volta la vita per francesco gabriele
giuliani caviglia per francesco gabriele
gianluigi giulia gianmarco enrico
beatrice saverio david e davide beatrice
davide la vigna pia francesco gabriele
gianluigi giulia gianmarco e ricco e
francesco giammarco e cesko gabriele
gianluigi giulia giammarco bene
ringrazio la vita per francesco gabriele
gianluigi giulia gianmarco enrico
beatrice saverio david e davide saverio
beatrice enrico gianmarco giulia gian
luigi gabriele de francesco davì mi è
sempre piaciuto questo video mettete un
pollice in su e lasciate un messaggio
scrivendo la famiglia che è il nostro
male guida voti
la razza di animale così mente
e già tutto di lei
ciao ciao